escombros y destrucción la fachada de
este edificio revela el asedio de las
tropas rusas aquí en el inmueble hace
parte de una zona residencial de la
capital que fue alcanzada por los
bombardeos de moscú el miércoles hace
unas semanas ataques como estos eran
impensables para los habitantes de la
zona
esperábamos que esto nunca sucedieran
quieres no tenemos ningún objetivo
militar aquí es sólo un área residencial
aquí no hay cuestiones industriales
cómo podemos sentirnos solo estábamos
viviendo nuestras vidas somos rusos toda
nuestra vida hemos hablado en ruso nadie
nos ha insultado nunca por ello
nadie nos ha obligado a hablar ucrania
no podemos hablar en cualquiera de los
dos idiomas
y ahí es nada
los bombardeos rusos sobre kiev se
intensifican según el alcalde de la
ciudad estos han provocado la muerte de
decenas de personas un panorama por el
cual en la ciudad entró en vigor un
toque de queda desde el martes hasta el
jueves también el martes los primeros
ministros de polonia república checa y
eslovenia visitaron la capital y
recalcaron en la necesidad urgente del
envío de ayuda humanitaria y armas
es aquí en la tierra devastada por la
guerra donde se está haciendo historia
es aquí que la libertad lucha contra el
mundo de la tiranía es aquí donde el
futuro de todos nosotros pende de un
hilo mientras tanto el presidente del
comité internacional de la cruz roja
peter maurer se reunió este miércoles
con el alcalde de la capital y aseguró
que la organización ya está
proporcionando la asistencia humanitaria
necesaria a la población civil maurer
también visitará moscú para pedir a
ambas partes que faciliten las labores
de asisten